in the favela arruda in Recife you can
see the poverty that has forced many of
its children into prostitution so the
seven people live in here
seventeen-year-old Rochelle began to
sell herself when she was 13
ready on of these days to pay out a debt
that I owe you 3 Reyes is about 80 pence
most of it fed Rachelle's crack
addiction I asked her mother Riza laid
how many of her children were
prostitutes on the beachfront of this
World Cup city young boys play football
but two streets back behind the hotel's
young girls are among the prostitutes
looking for trade well I mean all the
young looking girls that we've spoken to
look like they're about 16 15 age but
they're all saying they're 19 or 18
because that's the legal age and away
from the main red-light district we find
places where even younger children are
for sale we spoke to a man who described
himself as the street owner inside these
bottles is the cheapest drug on the
market
an ATP bottle of glue helps stave off
hunger and one child using the drug is
12 year old
Eleni do feel safe when you're here a
bit safe sometimes not sick talking to a
12 year old girl just a minute ago what
was her situation what's it like when
it's not good what happens was a foetus
present
bad things by grown-up people won't burn
out people boys that
yeah
it's heartbreaking this is a street of
lost
childhoods one close to the edge is
nine-year-old maiara not selling herself
yet but out late with addicts and child
prostitutes these are all your friends
these your friends yeah we learned from
others that her mother is a crack
cocaine addict living in one of her si
fees most dangerous drug ridden slums
next day we decide to go and find her
we're just walking into what's called
the favela of the rabbits although they
don't use the word favela anymore
because of the negative connotations of
the word it's associated with crime and
poverty so they call them communities
now but call them what you like there's
still very poor areas weaving through we
find Maya is living in the most deprived
corner of this slum her home barely
clinging to the riverbank we discover
her brother was murdered her father is
in prison and mayara
is the adult left comforting her addict
mother with the World Cup coming the
charity happy child which helps rescue
street children is warning many could be
traffic to tourist areas for
prostitution but the deeper problem
stems from places where the tourists
don't go where drugs and children are a
currency and for thousands like mayara
their fate seems almost unavoidable
Jason Ferrell Sky News Brazil